ce qui est important dans le cantal dans
le cancer du côlon est capable de
classifier rapidement images yonne jeune
entreprise spécialisée en intelligence
artificielle a développé un logiciel
pour repérer les polypes du côlon de
patients durant un examen médical
le logiciel les cibles les classes
identifie ce qui mériterait une biopsie
actuellement tous les polypes sont
enlevés ils sont envoyés en pathologie
mais d'analyser en pathologie des
polypes sont bénins lakota milliards de
dollars pour les 25 millions 15 copic
son fameux news corp le logiciel est
entraîné à reconnaître les polypes
suspects à partir de millions d' images
provenant de véritables examens médicaux
en moyenne un spécialiste identifie 80%
des polype cancéreux au sommet de son
art il atteint 90% images ya quoi
pouvoir faire aussi bien sinon mieux
mais l'entreprise qui développe aussi un
logiciel de reconnaissance des tumeurs
du poumon ne cherche pas à remplacer les
médecins on parle plutôt de travail des
équipes de deux erreurs qu'un humain
vaut faire que la machine fraport et
inversement
l'intelligence artificielle appliquée au
domaine médical la bio informatique est
en pleine expansion des géants comme ibm
et google y investissent des fortunes
son grand avantage sa capacité à
déterrer de l'information utile dans un
océan de données médicales brut
ces deux données qui sont tellement
massing que les chercheurs peuvent plus
travailler avec donc les agrumes
ce artificiel pour nous permettre de
débroussailler ces données leur
d'identifier un signal qu'on peut suivre
le chercheur travaille à la mise au
point d'un vaccin thérapeutique contre
le cancer à partir de milliards de
données tirées du génome humain sans
l'aide de l'intelligence artificielle sa
tâche serait presque impossible
on parle beaucoup présentement de
médecine de précisions on peut le
concevoir
en imaginant qu'on va rendre les
diagnostics beaucoup plus raffinés puis
associé des thérapies particulière à
chacun de ses dires et un stick raffiné
la fois certaines technologies
commencent même à faire leur place dans
le réseau de la santé
comme cette caméra couplée à de
l'intelligence artificielle qui sert à
dépister la rétinopathie diabétique une
grave maladie de l'oeil
le test prend 2 à 3 minutes il est
réalisé par un technicien plutôt qu'un
médecin le passeur a été violente au
créneau sur le char et après sa photo sa
photo est renvoyé les joueurs actuels
qui aimait le rapport donc tout fait de
façon beaucoup plus efficace bouclé
le logiciel un produit 100 % québécois a
appris à repérer sur la photo de l'oeil
les minuscules lésions causées par la
maladie
en analysant les résultats obtenus chez
250 mille patients de 16 pays différents
la machine bien qu'après c'est quoi les
lésions laissées religion à les
reconnaît facilement afin de revoir voir
revoir et hocine ouadah en achetant les
algorithmes et certaines conditions on
vient avec des très bons résultats
les spécialistes se repère 95% des cas
de rétinopathie diabétique
selon l'entreprise le logiciel peut
faire encore mieux la technologie
présentement à l'étude au chum dont les
spécialistes suivent 3000 patients
diabétiques
il intéresse akka technologies l'os
c'est que ça nous permet de dépister les
gens qui ont vraiment besoin de soins
spécialisés comme en ophtalmologie sait
on vraiment une atteinte plus tôt que
d'engorger toutes les cliniques
notamment le gel des patients qui ont
pas de problème ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal
le